This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. When Sophie Scott was about six, she came across her parents doing something very strange. They were rolling around, laughing. In my memory, they were actually on the floor of the living room. Absolutely overcome with laughter. They'd loved so much, they could literally do nothing else but laugh. What had got them laughing was a song. A comedy song about what people were not supposed to do in toilets on trains.
It's said to be quite a famous piece of music and it's gonna be customers. Well, please refrain from passing water while the train is in the station. Darling, I love you. We encourage constipation while the train is in the station, Darling, I love you. We encourage constipation, while the train is in the station. And as they remembered more and more of it, they got more and more helpless. If you wish to pass some water,
kindly call up the magher to the place of S.O. in the best. Now, maybe you're thinking, wait, this song isn't that funny. But we've all been there, right? You're with a friend, they say something ridiculous, and then your laughter triggers their laughter. Sophie didn't know then that laughter would play a big role in her life. But today she thinks about laughter a lot. She's a neuroscientist who studies the science of laughter. So she often thinks
back to that moment with her parents back when she was six. Years and years later my father was mortally ill. I mean he thought he was dying, we all thought he was dying. And the doctors didn't know what to do and it was all what we were just sitting around waiting for something to happen and he's my father suddenly said we've laughed a lot haven't we? And I said yes we have and I thought you know what's strange thing to say and it was years later when I was doing a lot more work on laughter I thought I know he was right you know if you can look back on a life where you've shared a lot of laughter with the people around you with the people that you care about those are are not times wasted. Those are the good times, those are the times that
really matter and letting yourself value that rather than thinking that it's a silly or retrieval waste of everyone's time, you should be spending your time being serious. You know, it is worth taking the laughter seriously. Today, we take laughter seriously. Sophie Skar tells us about the varied shades of laughter. From politeness... To discomfort... To delight. Decoding the meaning of laughter...
This week on Hidden Brain. Sophie Scott is a neuroscientist at University College London. She studies laughter, how laughter is processed by the brain, and the role it plays in shaping social connection. Sophie, welcome to Hidden Brain. Hi. I want to play you a't think I've ever heard that before. I'm assuming that is someone laughing, maybe not. I mean, when the point's about laughter is it's more like an animal call than it is like any human speech. So it can be extremely similar between humans and other animals. That's what I wanted to get to.
This is a clip of someone laughing uncontrollably, but it's almost as if another creature has taken this person over. You know, all the polish and the culture have gone out the window and you get these strange sounds. It's almost animalistic sounds. It really is. And we actually, in our normal day-to-day behavior,
humans have a lot of control over the things that we do in the sounds that we make and actually that's one of the things that's unusual about humans. We don't just react flexibly to our environment but we can modulate how we respond. A lot of other animals, particularly for vocalizations, their vocalizations are highly reflexive, something happens and they make the sound, something triggers the sound, they make the sound. And we have a handful of sounds that we make that are from this more kind of reflexive, involuntary route. And it can be quite startling when they come out of you.
Sounds like weeping, grunting, and gasp of surprise. A few weeks ago, I was doing a radio recording and unexpectedly we were in a chemistry lab, but there was an explosion. Anyway, let's just drive it in and see. And on tape, I made a proper kind of surprised, oh, sound. Oh! That was an involuntary vocalization, then.
I don't know if you noticed, I was not hoping to make cries. Because I was actually a little bit startled and I thought, oh, that's really irritating. I'm sure I haven't done that. But it was completely involuntary. And laughter can be like that as well. It can just feel like it's issuing forth from us. And we can make sounds when we're laughing like that.
That probably all other things being equal. We probably prefer not to make. It can be extremely, well, very animal. And it is animal. It's linking us exactly the same way that other animals make sounds. Sophie was drawn to studying laughter because she was interested in how humans express emotions. Most of the previous work on the subject had focused on visual cues.
Sophie asked, what about sounds? I got into laughter by being interested in non-verbal vocalization. So something like me going, oh, when I'm surprised, or screaming in terror. And I was working with those because we were interested in how humans recognize emotions and pretty much all the work on that is done with photographs of faces following in the beautiful work of people like Paul Ekman. And I was trying to come up with auditory vocal versions of those. So I was trying to steer away from emotional speech because the faces didn't have any verbal content to them. And it was looking at
those and then starting to look at different kinds of expressions that may be more positive emotions as well as negative emotions like fear and anger is what actually led me to laughter. So I never set out to study laughter. I was interested in these non-verbal sounds and they can be highly involuntary and in fact when we make them they are much more like animal cause than they are like speech. We don't do any of the fancy detailed movements of the lips and the jaw and the teeth and the tongue that we do when we're talking We in fact often the mouth doesn't do much at all You might pull a facial expression and then you just squeeze air out through the voice books
It is is there evidence that other animals laugh like humans laugh There is evidence that other animals laugh. So it's actually very easy to see it in other apes. In fact, Charles Darwin wrote quite a lot about this. Ape laughter is very, very similar to human... well, we're apes, you know. A non-human ape laughter is very similar to human laughter. So, if you were to hear a chimp laughing... It looks really like laughter, so you see, it's's very very visibly similar to human laughter. But there is also laughter like vocalizations that have been described in other animals
that aren't apes and are sort of somewhat further removed from us in an evolutionary term. So laughter has been well laughter like behavior has been described by Pankscap that the like neuroscientist and he was working with rats. And he noticed that rats make a very distinct vocalization when they're playing with each other. And they wondered if that was something like laughter, because laughter is strongly associated with play in apes.
And so they started tickling the rats, which is when you also find laughter in apes. And the rats make the same sound when they're tickled. They actually got rats in a cage and leaned in and tickled them, literally. Yes, yes and if you, what they find is that really important stuff, so rats definitely produce this vocalization when they're playing and when they're being tickled. And if they want you to tickle them, they will make the sound. And if they see you come into the lab and you normally tickle them, they make the sounds.
These sounds, by the way, are so high-pitched, they normally can't be heard by the human ear. You have to manipulate the recording to hear how rats respond to tickling. So it really does seem to be a kind of an invitation to players, PankSkept calls it, but it may not just be a trivial thing. So for example, you can do experiments with rats you can't do with humans. He found that the more you tickle a baby rat, when it's a baby, the more that rat will laugh when it's tickled as an adult. So you can potentiate laughter, the rats tell us, and some more recent work with laughter and rats is shown that if you remove the vocal cords of the voice box from rats, so they
can't make any vocal sounds. If you let those rats scrap and get it, you know, they'll be interact with other rats, they'll play with other rats, but they are more likely to be bitten if they play with another rat. Because one of the things that the love to vocalization is doing when the rats play with each other is it's signifying we're still playing, and it helps you manage that interaction because the same behaviour that happens during play could just spill over into aggression. And if you can't laugh, the data suggests from the rats, actually that's hard of you to manage. I want to play you one more clip that shows uncontrollable laughter and how strange it is. It's a clip that I think you're familiar with Sophie, two BBC commentators are talking
about a cricket game and I'm going to play the clip at a slightly extended version of the clip because it's worth hearing how this develops. He knew exactly what was going to happen. He tried to step over the stumps and just flick the bail with his right hand. He tried to do the splits so ridden. Unfortunately the inner part of his side must have just removed the bail. He just didn't quite go his leg over. He did very well indeed, about 131 minutes and hit three-fourths and then we had Louis playing extremely well for his 47-lone-out. Agas, do stop it.
Lawrence, always entertaining, about if a 35. 35 minutes hit a 4 of the weak he was I guess we can just say it's funny there's no one to say that I had to say it it's been a 4'm the weak human's head. He was a tough one. So Sophie, these are professional broadcasters on live radio. It's almost as if something has taken over. So the BBC very specifically gets cross with particularly news broadcasters and sports
broadcasters, sports broadcasters. People who are doing things live on BBC Radio, the BBC does not like them to laugh or show emotion, they call it breaking, and they knew they were going to get in trouble. They really didn't want to, you know, the situation is they don't want to be laughing, but when it's got, it's clause in you, it will happen. There's something unbelievably powerful about the way laughter can overwhelm our motor system. So it stops us breathing. It stops us talking. You heard they were completely unable to keep speaking and all they have to do is talk on the radio. It's what they do
for a living. And they're laughing, stopping them doing all that in. It just comes along. And basically, you have to just power through it. And right towards the end there, you heard Brian Johnson's voice, you get a time she can't talk at all. Other time she's going, he hits a four over the ring keeps that because he's trying to talk through the laughter. That's a very, very powerful thing to happen to actually render someone unable to speak,
is extraordinary. You know, there's two things that you said that jumped out at me. One is that, you know, so much of this was social. In other words, one of the commentators is telling the other one, please stop because if you don't stop, then I can't stop. And I've had that experience too
where you're laughing uncontrollably and you're telling the person next to you, you need to stop because if you don't stop, I don't have any control. So that's one interesting point. But the second interesting point is why would evolution create something in us that would essentially cut us off from being able to breathe?
It's very interesting. So if you're going back to your point about the social and the contagion, in some ways that is a pure example of behavioral contagion because they're both only laughing because the other one is laughing. Interestingly, if they didn't know each other, they'd be much less likely to share laughter that way because you don't catch laughter from someone you don't know or don't like in the same way as you catch from someone you know, maybe someone you like. And I think that's the other reason,
because the BBC likes playing that clip now. And I think that's because we know 25 years later that if those two men had hated each other, they would not have been laughing that way. Do you know what I mean? You're hearing something real actually there. That's a completely unmoderated joy in each other's company that is overruling everything else.
You know, I had a friend who visited the United States some time ago and this friend didn't speak English, but she was listening to a program that used to run on public radio called Cart talk. Hello and welcome to Cart Talk from National Public Radio, with us clicking on the tap at brothers. They essentially had these two guys talking about car repair, but really it was about the relationship between them
and they would be these extended sections of the show where the two of them essentially would be in hysterical laughter. I have the car for you, Steve. I'm ready. An El Camino. Ha ha ha ha. They just could not stop laughing at each other and at themselves. And my friend who did not speak English loved the show.
Yeah, even when you say to a Volvo owner, oh, it's going to be a thousand bucks, they say, oh, only a thousand. Because she said there's something about listening to these two people laugh, you know, out of control laughter that made her happy. There's something that language that laughter communicates that even perhaps goes beyond language. It does and I think part of it is because, you know, as your friend is experiencing, it is a universal emotion.
So wherever you go in the world, you'll encounter laughter and it has at its heart the same meaning. It's very truthful and it's telling you something very positive and that's always a sort of wonderful thing to encounter. Coming up, what makes us laugh? This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Here's how it usually goes. You're working from home and you call in by conference call for the morning meeting. Welcome. Please enter your access. Everyone is happily chatting around the table.
Yeah, exactly. That's fast. But as you sit there on mute, it all sounds very unfunny. You can't believe how much fun people seem to be having. Talking about nothing. Then someone starts to laugh. Soon, everyone's laughing. Except for you, silently listening on the phone, you're not even cracking a smile.
Forget about laughing. You wonder, when did this conversation become so hilarious? What am I missing? Well, it turns out laughter often isn't about responding to humor. It's an insight based on the work of laughter research at Robert Provin. Here's neuroscientist Sophie Scott. I thought that humor was the main thing that drove laughter. That's what I called laughter
for years when I was first working with it. I called it amusement. I thought, oh, it's an expression of amusement. And then I read Robert Provine's work. And Robert Provine is very clear. Although we think we laugh at humor and jokes, our label, our psychology, which I've shared, is that it's a reaction to humor. Most of the laughter that we produce is purely social in its origins. We laugh with other people. We're primed to laugh when we're with other people more than if we're on our own. And other social factors like, do we know those people? Do we like those people? That will feed into that. I understand some of the earlier research found that almost 80, 90% of the time, laughter
followed phrases like, I'll see you later, or it was nice meeting you, and things that were completely unfunny. Exactly, and it's because we laugh to show what we laugh to make and maintain social bonds. I mean, laughter can be a really efficient way of just smoothing over social interaction with somebody. But when we're with people that we're having a more enduring conversation with, the laughter is as much to do with showing agreement, showing understanding, showing recognition, you know, saying go on, yes I remember this, but carry on telling me, you know, it's got all this kind of nuanced meaning and, um, Provin's even found that at any point in time, the person who laughs most in a conversation
is the person who's talking, which really does suggest that it's being used in a very communicative way. So I wanna talk about the social nature of laughter and the context of laugh track. So this is an example of the media in some ways hijacking the way laughter operates in our brains. I wanna play you a clip from the TV show, Seinfeld.
What are you doing? What? Didn't, did you just double dip I want to play you a clip from the TV show, SignFeld. What are you doing? What? Didn't... Did you just double-dip that chip? Excuse me? You double-dip the chip! Double-dip what are you talking about? You dipped the chip, you took a bite,
and you dipped again. So, what do... what do... what do... Laft tracks tell us about the social nature of laughter, Sophie? Well, the interesting story of laugh tracks is that they became a necessity when we started to be able to record and broadcast programs that we were hoping people would find funny, because the natural home of laughter is in social settings. And in theatrical and performance environments environments people would be laughing, they'd laugh at the theatre, they'd laugh at musical, they'd laugh at people doing performance stuff.
But that was always be a shared experience. You were in an audience and you were part of a group of people laughing and as soon as you go down to something that's being broadcast, people don't necessarily get all those cues. So suddenly they were finding that people weren't necessarily hearing a radio program as sounding funny because there were no cues to help you hear that. So a solution to this problem of people that's not necessarily finding things funny if there wasn't the sound of laughter, but also studio laughter, sometimes being hard to control. Charles Douglas, who was a sound engineer, invented a sort of a laugh box where he had recordings of laughter which he could mix together and drop in and then this became very easily controlled
because you then have this technique for being able to have exactly as much laughter as you want at the time that you wanted, without having to worry about the empty silences or uncontrollable studio laughter. And it's kind of incredible, isn't it, which is in some ways the studio is manipulating when you laugh, not with the jokes, but with the laugh machine. I suppose in a sense they always were. It is interesting that if you look at because some programs carried on making a point of saying, you know, this is filmed in front of a live studio audience, so Seinfeld is an example, cheers, friends, they would make it quite a big deal that you knew this thing was being performed in front of an
audience, and in fact friends would, they would do a whole rehearsal with a live audience there and look at when people laughed, then go away and reworked lines so you could maximize the relationships and what was being said and when the laughter happened. So they were almost being scientists about it, which is a manipulative. It's all trying to control the audience laughter because it's considered to be something that makes it sound better. And I think one of the things that's interesting about studio laughter or candelarfters as people started calling the, you know, an extra recording that's been dropped in is that one of them started to be very, considered to be very infred, you know, not quite the thing. So we became a
bit snobbish about Candlafter. In the UK, I think, Mash was famously shown without Candlafter in the US. It was. I need my things. Oh yeah, I packed your toothbrush with jammies and one of your slingshots. You jerk face, that's my garter belt. It has quite a different experience watching the two. I need my things. Oh yeah, I packed your toothbrush with jammies and one of your slingshots. You jerk face, that's my garter belt. It sort of became a bit of a cultural thing about whether or not you had laughter on it at all, so it became more of a fashion for comedy to not need that.
So things like the office in the UK didn't have a laughter track of any kind, and would have looked down a little bit, I suspect, on programmes that felt they needed to. So you know, it's definitely, it's not just the laughter, and whether the laughter is live or canned, it's to do with your view of the sort of programs that might need laughter, or do you think they need laughter. You know, are understanding of laugh tracks gets a bit nuanced? Hmm. You said a second ago that people can be snobbish about laugh tracks, but people are also
in some ways snobbish about laughter. We think of one kind of laughter as real and and one kind of lafter as fake, so the social greeting laughter we think of as fake and we think about the rolling on the floor helpless with lafter as real. Is social laughter fake and spontaneous laughter real? Well, at one level they are, and you know, it's the case that the spontaneous laughter, the kind of stuff you cannot stop doing, is definitely different to laughter that at some level, is a performative or a communicative element.
And I must admit, sometimes I call them real and fake laughter just because it's very easy and people know what I mean. But I'm very well aware that when you call it fake, you are valancing it, you're making it sound like it's a bad thing. And of course, most of the time, the vast majority of the time, it's not a bad thing at all, it's a great thing. You recognise the meaning of laughter that a friend gives you or someone gives you, it has a positive aspect to it.
And the fact that somebody's giving you their laughter, the fact that they're actually choosing to produce that laughter for you, we've found that people actually seem to be marking the communicative laughter. For example, in the UK, it can quite often be very nasal, but that sounds to it. You couldn't do that if you were laughing spontaneously, and that really does suggest that people are going out of their way to say, look, I'm giving this to you. This is laughter I'm trying to produce for you. In an interaction where you like the person, you have a good relationship with that person, you know what that means and you take it. I think the situations where we
get upset by laughter that sounds put on is when we don't know those people, you've ever been on a train with a load of friends who all seem to be sitting there and they're like, ha ha ha! And you're like, oh, goodness me, they're all faking that laughter. Because if you're one of the friends, you wouldn't care at all. This is because you're not part of that group. You are isolated from it, and you're hearing the performanceiveness rather than the warmth. And also if you're either, I tried this isn't science,
but if you think about it, there's some of you know who laughs really and appropriately, who hasn't it retating laugh. If you think about that, most people can think of someone. And I've never found anyone who really likes that person. So actually, so I have a relative who's always I've always thought, oh, they laugh really inappropriately. And so working with the laughter, I've realized it's because there's nothing inappropriate about their laughter. I don't join in with it because I don't really like them. And it's me with holding my laughter that I'm experiencing is them doing something wrong.
And they're laughter being irritating, but it's not, it's me that's being different. So that's an interesting insight because what you're saying is that it's your affection or lack of affection that prompts you to see that laughter is being inappropriate or appropriate or enjoyable. So it's really, we think in the conventional way we think, someone has an inappropriate laugh, I don't like it, but really, you don't like them, and that's why you think the laugh is inappropriate. I think so, and I think, actually, this is a hypothesis.
Let's be generous. I don't have any data to back this up, but I think we do that quite a lot with laughter, because we do the opposite as well. If somebody makes us laugh, we will say, oh, they're hilarious, they're a great sense of human, they make us laugh. What they mean is, I really like them. I really like them and I laugh and I'm around them so that they will know that I like them and maybe they'll like me too. You know, it's a, it's a, it's a, but we attribute it to other people. We attribute our laughter to other people, or our lack of laughter. We attribute to other people. Laughter in other words can tell us a lot about relationships between people.
It's a signaling device. But how are we so good at decoding what laughter means? Sophie had a hunch. She conducted an experiment to show that the brain actually processes different kinds of laughter differently. She recruited a couple of people to join her on her London campus. She invited them into a strange little hut. Inside this hut was a windowless room where all the surfaces were covered with wedges of foam and the only things in the room were a pair of speakers, a chair and a computer monitor that was bolted
to the wall. Once the door was closed, you could finally encounter true silence and experience few people could tolerate for more than a few minutes. Inside this tiny, joyless chamber, Sophie recorded herself and the two other people laughing. It is a weird little space because it's perfect for making absolutely beautiful recordings, but it's sort of antithetical to getting people laughing. She used a few tricks. She started slow. We spent a long time warming them up before we tried to put anyone in the Anacot chamber
and make, on their own to laugh. And then we'd make sure that the person in the Anacot chamber, when they did, you know, when they were laughing, we kind of throw them in their clothes at the door and start recording. Once she had her beautiful recordings of different kinds of laughter, she played these clips for volunteers as the lay inside a brain scanning machine. Her question, would the brain register the difference between laughter that was polite and laughter that was spontaneous? And what we find is people hear laughter and they start trying to work out what it means
and if the laughter is spontaneous, you get a different pattern of neural activation than if the laughter is, at some level, being intentionally produced. And in fact, that is reflected in the brain activation, you see. When the volunteers heard uncontrolled belly laughs, the brain scans showed they focused on the sound of the laughter. But when they heard the recordings of the polite chuckles, the brains can't suggest it, the volunteers were thinking. They were asking the question, what's really going on here? For Sophie, the experiment confirmed that laughter always means something.
It's a code we're always trying to decipher. This might be why most of us can tell the difference between laughter among friends and laughter among strangers. It turns out you don't need to know anything about the two people laughing. You don't even need to see them. All you need to know anything about the two people laughing. You don't even need to see them. All you need to do is hear them laugh for one second. Some years ago, the cognitive scientist Greg Bryant at UCLA recorded pairs of friends and pairs of strangers having a conversation.
He pulled out all the moments when they laughed and then cut the laughter into tiny bursts that lasted just a second. He and his colleagues played these tiny little laughter clips for nearly a thousand people from 24 societies all over the world. The researchers asked the volunteers if they could tell whether the people laughing were friends or strangers. Why don't you see if you can tell the difference? Here's one set of three laughs strung together. And here's another. If you guessed that the first clip was strangers and the second clip was friends, you're right. Most people in the study got it right. People all over the world could hear the difference. And it makes sense because we don't laugh with just anybody.
You know, laughter is a very good index of how we feel about what people that we're with. And it's not like we're laughing or we're not laughing and that's the only difference. You can have much more kind of performative, you know, if I bump into someone in the street and we both laugh and say we're okay, I'm not going to stand again. That laughter wasn't very intense because I know what it means. Like, you know, it was doing its job of sorting out a slightly difficult situation. Whereas with a friend, the laughter is likely to be much warmer because it needs to be and it can be and it's an index actually of how those friends feel about each other.
你知道，笑声能很好地反映出我们对同行之人的感受。这并不是说要么在笑、要么没笑，这就是唯一的区别。你可以有更多表演性质的笑，你知道的，如果我在街上撞到某个人，我们都笑笑并说没事，我可不会再站过去。那个笑并不是很强烈，因为我知道它意味着什么。就像，你知道的，它起到了化解略微尴尬局面的作用。而对朋友而言，笑声往往要温暖得多，因为这是需要也是能够做到的，它其实是这些朋友彼此感受的一个指标。
So, I think it's interesting that we're so alive to it, like we really notice it. And as I say, I think that's because it's incredibly important social signal and we recognise its emotional meaning. This emotional meaning is usually positive, but not always. When we come back, the connection between laughter and power. During the 2018 Supreme Court confirmation hearing for then-judge Brett Kavanaugh, there was a moment when the role of laughter took center stage. California psychologist Christine Blasey Ford had accused Kavanaugh of sexually assaulting her when they were both teenagers in Maryland.
所以，我觉得很有意思的是，我们对它是如此敏感，我们真的能注意到它。正如我所说，我认为这是因为它是一个极其重要的社会信号，我们能识别它的情感含义。这种情感含义通常是积极的，但并非总是如此。接下来的节目中，我们将探讨笑声与权力的联系。在2018年时任法官布雷特·卡瓦诺（Brett Kavanaugh）的最高法院提名听证会上，有一个时刻，笑声的作用成为了焦点。加州心理学家克里斯蒂娜·布莱西·福特（Christine Blasey Ford）指控卡瓦诺在马里兰州他们都还是青少年时对她实施了性侵。
She said that Kavanaugh had leaped on top of her and tried to disrupt her at a party while a friend watched. Kavanaugh's treasonously denied the allegations. The US Senate invited Christine Blasie for to testify and Senate a Patrick Leahy asked her about the allegation. What is the strongest memory you have? Strongest memory of the incident, something that you cannot forget. Take whatever time you need.
她称卡瓦诺在一场派对上扑到她身上，试图打扰她，而旁边有一个朋友在看。卡瓦诺强烈否认了这些指控。美国参议院邀请克里斯蒂娜·布莱西·福特作证，参议员帕特里克·莱希（Patrick Leahy）就这一指控向她提问。你拥有的最深刻的记忆是什么？关于这次事件的最深刻的记忆，一处你永远无法忘记的地方。请花点时间，随时都可以。
Indelegable in the hippocampus is the laughter, the the aperious laughter between the two. And they're having fun at my expense. You'd ever forgotten that laughter. You'd never forgotten them laughing at you. They were laughing with each other. And you were the object of the laughter? And you were the object of the laughter? I was, you know, underneath one of them, while the two laughed.
海马体中铭刻不去的是笑声，两人之间那种傲慢的笑声。他们拿我寻开心。你永远不会忘记那种笑。你永远不会忘记他们嘲笑你。他们彼此对笑。而你成了被嘲笑的对象？而你成了被嘲笑的对象？是的，你知道的，我被压在其中一个人身下，而两人却在一旁大笑。
Two friends having a really good time with one another. Sophie, I don't want you to get into the debate of a Kavanaugh, but as a researcher who studies laughter, how do you respond to our Christian 4 to all the Senate? Well, it's almost unbearable to listen to, but it's also very recognizable because if you think about laughter as being about making and maintaining social bonds, it has to mean by definition that someone is excluded from that bond. Otherwise, it doesn't mean anything. So we normally dwell on the positive side of that look. We're making and maintaining social bonds and that's great. But if you are excluded from that, you're excluded from that laughter.
两个朋友彼此玩得很开心。苏菲，我不想让你卷入关于卡瓦诺的辩论中，但作为一个研究笑声的研究人员，你如何看待我们克里斯蒂娜·福特在参议院的证词？嗯，听起来几乎让人难以忍受，但它也非常具有辨识度，因为如果你认为笑声是为了建立和维持社会纽带，那么根据定义，它必然意味着有人被排斥在这个纽带之外。否则，这就没有任何意义。所以我们通常关注这种笑声积极的一面。看，我们在建立和维持社会纽带，这很棒。但如果你被排斥在外，你就会被排斥在那个笑声之外。
It's awful. And it's awful because we have a very, very strong understanding of what that means. And there's a lot more to this. There's the situation where something terribly serious is happening from your perspective, something terribly serious is happening from your perspective, something awfully serious is happening, that is being treated as fun by other people. There was a court case in the UK recently where a woman's son had been
这太糟糕了。之所以糟糕，是因为我们对这意味着什么有着非常非常深刻的理解。而且这其中还有更多的内涵。有时会出现这种情况：从你的角度来看，有极其严重的事情正在发生，从你的角度来看，有极其严重的事情正在发生，有极其可怕的事情正在发生，却被其他人当成好玩的事来对待。英国最近发生了一起法庭案件，一个女人的儿子遭到
murdered and in the court, the two young men who were up for his murder were laughing and joking and she made a statement precisely about this, they can't even take this seriously. You know, my son's death and they're going to go to prison for it and they are still laughing. And I can totally understand one that was almost the worst part of what was going on for her. That's like marking how little they care about your situation. So it can be very powerful, that kind of distinction,
谋杀，在法庭上，因谋杀他而被起诉的那两个年轻男子却在嬉皮笑脸、说笑逗趣，她专门就此发表了一份声明，他们甚至无法认真对待这件事。你知道的，我儿子的死，他们将为此入狱，可他们居然还在笑。我完全能理解，对她来说，这几乎是整件事中最糟糕的部分。这就好比在标榜他们对你的处境是多么不在乎。因此，这种区别会非常有力量，
who is laughing at who, who is got a bound with who and who's being excluded from that can be a very, very marked way of not just excluding somebody from a social group, but actually marking them as inferior and we have this behaviour that's being done by the people who are more important, the people who have greater status, they can find something fun and enjoyable because they're the ones with the power. And in some ways laughter is a way to reinforce status isn't it? I mean, I'm thinking about schools, for example, when you think about bullying and schools, one of the things that
谁在嘲笑谁，谁和谁是一伙的，谁被排斥在外，这不仅可以成为将某人排斥在社会群体之外的一种非常非常明显的途径，而且实际上还将其打上低人一等的烙印，而且这种行为是由那些更重要的人、地位更高的人做出来的，他们能找到好玩和享受的事，因为他们是掌权者。在某种程度上，笑声是巩固地位的一种方式，不是吗？我的意思是，我以学校为例，当你想到学校里的霸凌时，其中一件事就是
happens is if a group of kids is laughing at another kid, the kid who is isolated is recognizes the experience of being isolated partly by who is laughing at him or her. Absolutely. So again, it's the same laughter can be incredibly warm, positive, friendly doing all its work for the people within the social group and then be absolutely awful to the person who's being not only excluded from it but is the target for the laughter. And it's one of the worst sensations, you know, if you realise not only are people laughing and they're not, you're nothing to do with it, but actually no, hang on there laughing and they're laughing at
如果一群孩子在嘲笑另一个孩子，那个被孤立的孩子就会意识到被孤立的经历，部分原因正是由于谁在嘲笑他或她。绝对是这样。所以同样的笑声，既可以无比温暖、积极、友好，为社交群体中的人们发挥所有积极作用，又会对那个不仅被排斥在外、而且成为嘲笑目标的当事人造成绝对糟糕的影响。这是一种最糟糕的感觉，你知道的，如果你意识到人们不仅在笑，而且这与你毫无关系，相反——等等，听着，他们是在笑，而且他们是在
you. It's just sickening, it's horrible feeling because it's one of the most basic things we care about as humans. We're social primates who we get to hang out with, who talks to us, who's what social network we're part of, that really matters. And when you get this absolutely clear example not only are you excluded from this group but they would care so little to have you be part of them that they would mark you out as being worthy being laughed at. It's almost extraordinary. You can see the power of laughter to
嘲笑你。这简直让人反胃，这是一种可怕的感觉，因为这是我们作为人类最关心的最基本的事情之一。我们是社会性灵长类动物，我们和谁一起闲逛，谁和我们说话，我们属于哪个社交网络，这些真的非常重要。当你得到这样一个绝对清晰的例子：你不仅被这个群体排斥在外，而且他们根本不在乎让你成为他们的一部分，以至于他们把你标榜为值得嘲笑的对象。这几乎是非同寻常的。你可以看到笑声的
bond and the power of laughter to exclude in one of the most famous clips in the news from the last few years. In 2005, Celebrity TV host Donald Trump was on his way to film an episode of Access Hollywood. He was having a casual conversation with Billy Bush, a younger man known for his easy rapport with celebrities. Trump was talking about the woman he was about to meet. Yeah, that's it. With a gold, I'm going to use some text just in case I start kissing her. Pay attention here to the role that laughter plays in their exchange. You know, I'm automatically attracted to beautiful. I just start kissing them. It's like a magnet. I don't need a way. And when you're a star, they let you do it. You can do anything. Whatever you want.
凝聚力以及笑声的排他性，这在过去几年新闻中最著名的片段之一中得到了体现。2005年，名人电视主持人唐纳德·特朗普在前往拍摄一集《好莱坞内幕》（Access Hollywood）的途中。他与比利·布什（Billy Bush）进行了一场轻松的对话，后者是一个以长于与名人打成一片而闻名的年轻人。特朗普当时正在谈论他即将见面的那个女人。对，就是那个。带着黄金，我要用点词以防我开始亲吻她。在这里注意笑声在他们的对话中扮演的角色。你知道的，我对美女有一种天然的吸引力。我直接就开始亲吻她们。就像磁铁一样。我根本不需要等。当你是个明星时，他们就会允许你这么做。你可以为所欲为。无论你想做什么。
Grab them but f***. I can do anything. Sophie Scott argues that powerful people often use laughter as a way to cover up misdeeds and indiscretions. When they are called out on their behavior, they say they are joking. That it was just locker room talks. Whoa! Yes, the doubt of this word. on their behavior, they say they are joking, that it was just locker room talks.
抓住她们，然后……我什么都能做。苏菲·斯科特认为，有权势的人经常用笑声来掩盖不当行为和轻率举动。当他们的行为受到质疑时，他们会说自己是在开玩笑。说这只是更衣室里的谈话。哇！没错，这就是这个词的含义。针对他们的行为，他们说自己是在开玩笑，这只是更衣室里的谈话。
Because we aren't very good at understanding that most of our life is nothing to do with humor, we can mistake the fact that people who are laughing in a situation with us aren't laughing because what we said was funny, they're laughing because they like us and they're part of the same group as us. But if you go away from that, you know, if you were to choose to take from that, oh, I'm hilarious, then you could also choose to use that as your defence for somebody else objecting to what was going on there. And it's a very, very common one. Often I think when people say it was just locker room chats, it was, I was being funny. What they mean is, you know, I almost don't need to justify myself to you.
因为我们并不擅长理解我们的生活中大多数事情与幽默无关，所以我们可能会产生误解：在一个情境中和我们一起笑的人，并不是因为我们说的话好笑才笑，他们笑是因为他们喜欢我们，而且他们和我们属于同一个群体。但如果你脱离了这一点，你知道的，如果你从中得出结论“噢，我太搞笑了”，那么你也可以选择以此作为借口，来应对别人对当时情况提出的异议。这是一个非常非常普遍的现象。通常我认为当人们说“这只是更衣室聊天，我当时在搞笑”时，他们的意思是，你知道的，我几乎不需要向你解释自己。
But I think also, it can kind of conflate difficult, in a difficult way with this notion of power because it is the case that if you look at strongly hierarchical situations, I think there was work with doctors in the UK where the senior doctor will have a very different sort of social status than the junior doctors in his or her group and there was data showing that the junior doctors would laugh at something the senior doctor said and the senior doctornier if it's produced by the senior person. I think it's also as likely that the junior people are trying to make themselves
但我也认为，这可以以一种困难的方式与权力的概念交织在一起，因为事实确确实实是，如果你看看等级森严的环境，我想英国的医生群体中曾有过这样的研究：资深医生与他或她组里的初级医生相比，具有截然不同的社会地位，数据表明，初级医生会顺着资深医生的话笑，而资深医生也是如此。如果这是由资深人士引发的话。我认为初级人员同样也是为了让资深人士
liked by the senior person by giving them the laughter. You know, it's something we will actively try and use around people. But it does mean that bosses who might have got used to people laughing at what they say and are not realising it's because of who they are, rather than what they're saying. May find themselves in a situation where they have said something genuinely offensive, and when they get called on it, they can't, you know,
喜欢自己而迎合对方的笑声。你知道的，这是我们会积极尝试在人们周围使用的一种手段。但这确实意味着，那些习惯了别人对他们说的话发出笑声的老板们，可能没有意识到这是因为他们的身份，而不是因为他们的话。他们可能会发现自己陷入这样一种境位：他们说了真正具有冒犯性的话，而当别人质问他们时，他们却无法，你知道的，
they were all just, it was just banter, I was just being hilarious, but what they were simply straight up offensive. Laughter can also be used by the weak to hold a powerful to account. Historians talk about the role of the court-gester, often the only one who could speak truth to power, usually through a laugh. Even in countries with authoritarian regimes, laughter can be a slighway to undermine leaders and register discontent. I ask Sophie if laughter could be the weapon of the week.
他们当时只是……这只是玩笑，我只是在搞笑，但他们其实就是赤裸裸地出言不逊。弱者也可以利用笑声来追究当权者的责任。历史学家们谈到过宫廷小丑的角色，他们往往是唯一能对当权者说真话的人，通常是通过笑声。即使在拥有威权政体的国家里，笑声也可以成为一种暗中破坏领导人和表达不满的微妙方式。我问苏菲，笑声是否会成为弱者的武器。
It can just be a straightforward weapon, so to be clear it doesn't only have to be used by the week, but it can work very well. So laughter can be a very good way of rather than just getting angry about somebody, pointing out enormous shortcomings in their statements or their behaviour, in a way that creates people laugh. Because they are signalling on a playful intent and they're also clearly mocking them, you were excluding them and laughing at them. Sometimes there was a UK Prime Minister John Major who never really recovered from some journalist spotting when they were on the campaign trail with him that he tucked his shirt into his underpants.
它完全可以成为一种直接的武器，所以需要明确的是，它不仅能被弱者使用，而且能发挥很好的作用。因此，笑声可以成为一种极好的方式，比起单纯对某人生气，它能以一种引人发笑的方式指出对方言论或行为中的巨大缺陷。因为他们在发出一种好玩的意图信号，而且他们也显然在嘲弄对方，你在排斥他们并嘲笑他们。有时候，英国前首相约翰·梅杰（John Major）就从来没有真正从一些记者的嘲笑中恢复过来——当记者们在竞选活动中跟随他时，发现他把衬衫下摆塞进了内裤里。
You could sort of see it through his, you know, you got very close to him. And they just became relentless. Now it was by no means his worst crime was a prime minister, a political person, but it was like the thread that was easily pulled out and everything kind of fell from there. You know, it was, it was absolutely relentless and how that was run with. Laughter can also be used to hold other people at a distance. In our current politics, both liberals and conservatives love to mark each other. It's a way of not having to listen to people you disagree with.
你甚至可以透过他的，你知道的，离他很近时看到。而他们只是毫不留情地抓住不放。现在这绝不是他作为首相、作为政治人物犯下的最严重的罪行，但这就像是一根很容易被抽出来的线，随之而来的一切都土崩瓦解了。你知道的，这种做法简直毫不留情，而且被大肆渲染。笑声也可以用来与他人保持距离。在我们当前的政治中，自由派和保守派都喜欢互相羞辱。这是一种不必倾听与自己意见不合的人说话的方式。
Laughter becomes a weapon to solidify the distaste that each tribe has for the other. The elite! Why are they elite? I have a much better apartment than they do. I'm smarter than they are. I'm richer than they are. Because it turns out the name Trump was not always his family's name. One biographer found that a press-int-ancester had changed it from, and this is true, Trump. Yes!
笑声成了巩固各阵营彼此厌恶情绪的武器。精英！为什么他们是精英？我的公寓比他们的好得多。我比他们聪明。我比他们更有钱。因为事实证明，特朗普（Trump）这个名字并不总是他家族的名字。一位传记作家发现，他的一位曾祖父曾把这个名字改过，千真万确，改成了特朗普。太棒了！
Oh, f***! Trump! It's grouping writ large. You know, these big social groups. You can sort of see it in the UK around Brexit with both sides trying to paint the other as ridiculous and to better or less success, be funny about it.
哦，操！特朗普！这就是群体化行为的放大版。你知道的，这些大的社会群体。你在英国的“脱欧”事件中也能看到这一点，双方都试图把对方描绘成荒谬可笑的形象，并且无论成功与否，都试图拿它来开玩笑。
You're using it to mark the commonality with the group of people you share something with as well as your difference from and sort of separation from and the ridiculousness of that other group. We've talked a lot about your research and your ideas, but I understand that for the past a few years you've also a stand-up comedian yourself. Do you remember how you felt the first time you got a really big laugh? I can tell you how I felt before then I don't think I've ever been so nervous. Not since my exam at school I'm literally at one point locked myself in the toilet thought I was just staying
你用它来标榜你所认同的那群人的共性，同时也标榜你与另一个群体的差异、隔离以及对方的荒谬可笑。我们已经聊了很多关于你的研究和你的想法，但我了解到，在过去的几年里，你其实自己也是一名单口喜剧演员。你还记得自己第一次听到真正放声大笑时的感受吗？我可以告诉你我那之前的感受，我从来没有这么紧张过。自从学校考试以来都没有过，我在某个时刻甚至把自己反锁在洗牙间里，心想我索性就待
here you know I don't have to come out ever. And the first time I got a laugh, and it wasn't a laugh I was expecting, it wasn't on a line, I thought it was funny. I thought, oh, it's all, you know, I can see light at the end of the tunnel, I'm gonna be able to get through this. But the bit I really remember, when you finish the, you know,
在这儿得了，你知道的，我永远都不用出去了。而我第一次收获笑声时，那并不是我预料中的笑声，那甚至不是一句台词，我当时觉得这很好笑。我想，噢，这一切，你知道的，我看到了隧道尽头的曙光，我能挺过这一关了。但我真正记得的部分是，当你完成，你知道的，
stand up normally in the UK, there's an MC who comes on and claps, mic, you know, and the guy came, I left the stage and this guy came out and went, ladies and gentlemen, so big, you know, I was capping and I was like, yes! So perfect! People can carry on doing this for as long as they would do, this is pure hits of dopamine to my nucleus of couples, you know, perfect. And then, and then really my next coherent thought was, I want to do that again and I want to do it better. I want to learn how to do this.
在英国演完单口喜剧之后，通常会有一个主持人上台鼓掌，拿麦克风，你知道的，那个家伙上来了，我下了台，这家伙出来说：“女士们先生们，太棒了，你知道的，”我当时在鼓掌，然后我就想：“太棒了！太完美了！”人们可以一直这样做下去，这简直是注入我纹状体的纯正多巴胺，你知道的，太完美了。然后，然后我接下来真正连贯的想法是：我还想再来一次，而且我要做得更好。我想学会怎么做好这件事。
It's very hard to say this without sounding like you, I don't know, the undead, but I like brains and I work with brains. And I'm very lucky because I get to use a technique called Functional Magnetic. Because I only did it in the first base, that's a professional jealousy. I had no plans to set out and get into standard comedy
说这话时很难不让自己听起来像个，我不知道，像个僵尸，但我喜欢大脑，我也研究大脑。我很幸运，因为我能使用一种叫做功能磁共振的技术。因为我一开始就这么做了，那是职业嫉妒。我从未计划过要涉足单口喜剧，
until I tried it and then I wanted to get better at it. I wanted to understand it as a skill. Mae'n gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaith No one is fooled when they see me. No one's thinking, oh, this is the upcoming young comedian. They know I'm a scientist. They don't have an academic. I'm not presenting myself as anything other than that. Well, what I try and do is I take real science and I take stories, things that have happened to me or my family and I try and turn that into a short, informative, but hilarious set.
直到我尝试了之后，我才想把它做得更好。我想把它当作一项技能来理解。谁看到我都不会被糊弄。没有人会想，噢，这是一个很有前途的年轻喜剧演员。他们知道我是个科学家。他们知道我是个学者。我展现出来的就是这个身份，别无其他。好吧，我尝试做的是，我取材于真实的科学和真实的故事，那些发生在我身上或我家人身上的事情，我试着把这些转化为简短、信息丰富但又妙趣横生的段子。
But what I quite often do is actually take examples of things that have been upsetting. a ffodd yn ffodd yn ffodd yn ffodd yn ffodd yn ffodd yn ffodd yn ffodd yn ffodd yn ffodd yn ffodd yn ffodd yn ffodd yn ffodd yn ffodd yn ffodd yn ffodd yn ffodd yn ffodd yn ffodd yn ffodd yn ffodd yn ffodd yn ffodd yn ffodd yn ffodd yn ffodd yn ffodd yn ffodd yn ffodd yn ffodd yn ffodd yn ffodd yn ffodd yn ffodd yn ffodd yn ffodd yn ffodd yn ffodd yn ffodd yn ffodd yn ffodd yn ffodd yn ffodd yn ffodd yn ffodd yn ffodd yn ffodd yn ffodd yn ffodd yn ffodd yn ffodd yn ffodd yn ffodd yn ffodd yn ffodd yn ffodd yn ffodd yn ffodd yn ffodd yn ffodd yn ffodd yn ffodd yn ffodd yn ffodd yn ffodd yn ffodd yn ffodd yn ffodd yn ffodd yn ffodd yn ffodd yn ffodd yn ffodd yn ffodd yn ffodd yn ffodd yn ffodd yn ffodd yn ffodd yn ffodd yn ffodd yn ffodd yn ffodd yn ffodd yn ffodd yn ffodd yn ffodd yn ffod have to go home and now they're a group of teenage boys laughing at me because I looked the wrong way. And you think, oh, this is an interesting situation isn't it scientifically? What's going on here? Well, let's take a think about it. What can science tell us? If we look at the science in the future, quite good because I could kind of take off all the different aspects about laughter that I could learn from this interaction, but also it made me feel a lot better about what happened on it's switch railway station because I had ownership over it and I got laughter out of it and every time an audience laughs at that routine, Mae'n gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweith in a pair of viewed publication. And the next time those teenage boys pick up the December 2014 edition of Trends and Coge of Neurocies. They'll be laughing on the other side of their faces.
但我经常做的一件事，其实是取材于那些令人沮丧的事情。要回家了，现在有一群十几岁的男孩子在嘲笑我，因为我走错了方向。然后你会想，噢，从科学的角度来看，这是一个很有趣的对吧？这里发生了什么？好吧，我们来思考一下。科学能告诉我们什么？如果我们着眼于未来的科学，那就太好了，因为我可以剖析我能从这次互动中了解到的关于笑声的所有不同方面，而且这也让我对发生在斯维奇火车站的事情感觉好多了，因为我掌控了它，我从这件事中收获了笑声，并且每当观众对这个段子发笑时，发表在同行评议的期刊上。下次那群十几岁的男孩子拿起2014年12月版的《认知神经科学趋势》（Trends in Cognitive Neurosciences）时。他们就会笑不出来了。
Thank you very much. Sophie Scott is a neuroscientist at University College London, where she studies the science of laughter. Sophie, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you very much. I hope you enjoyed myself. This episode was produced by Laura Correll, edited edited by Tara Boyle and Kimela Vargas Restrepo.
非常感谢。苏菲·斯科特是伦敦大学学院的神经科学家，她在那里研究笑声的科学。苏菲，非常感谢你今天做客《隐藏的大脑》（Hidden Brain）。非常感谢。我自己过得很愉快。本期节目由劳拉·科雷尔（Laura Correll）制作，由塔拉·博伊尔（Tara Boyle）和基梅拉·巴尔加斯·雷斯特雷波（Kimela Vargas Restrepo）编辑。
Our team includes Jenny Schmidt, Reyna Cohen, Thomas Liu, and Parth Shah. Our onslaught hero this week is my colleague Steven Thompson, who works at NPR Music. Steven sends out periodic notes announcing guests, who are going to perform at the Tani-desk concert series at NPR, and his notes are invariably filled with funny observations about his boss, his green Bay Packers football team, and sunsets. These emails, like the one about eating between 15 and 25 bowls of cereal one Friday night, do something we could all use more often our lives, they make us laugh. You can hear Stephen for yourself on NPR's
我们的团队成员包括珍妮·施密特（Jenny Schmidt）、雷娜·科恩（Reyna Cohen）、托马斯·刘（Thomas Liu）和帕思·沙阿（Parth Shah）。本周我们的幕后英雄是我的同事史蒂芬·汤普森（Steven Thompson），他在NPR音乐频道工作。史蒂芬会定期发送邮件，宣布将在NPR的“小亭子音乐会”（Tiny Desk Concert）系列中演出的嘉宾，他的邮件总是充满了对他的老板、绿湾包装工队橄榄球队以及日落的有趣观察。这些电子邮件，就像那封关于在一个周五晚上吃掉15到25碗麦片的邮件一样，做了一件我们所有人都希望在生活中多做一点的事——它们让我们开怀大笑。你可以在NPR的
Pop Culture Happy Hour podcast. Oh! Oh! Oh! Oh! Oh! Oh! Oh!
《流行文化欢乐时光》（Pop Culture Happy Hour）播客中听到史蒂芬的声音。噢！噢！噢！噢！噢！噢！噢！
Oh! Oh! Oh! Oh! I'm Shankar Vita Anthem. See you next week. Because actually most people don't really like being tickled. I was doing a talk at the Royal Society a few years ago.
噢！噢！噢！噢！我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆（Shankar Vedantam）。下周见。因为其实大多数人并不真的很喜欢被挠痒痒。几年前我在皇家学会（Royal Society）做过一次演讲。
This very elderly, very distinguished member of the Royal Society, fellow of the Royal Society went, I love to be tickled. I am not going to tickle you, sir. That's not, that's not most people's reaction. Different show, different show Sophie. It's not going to tickle you, sir. That's not most people's reaction. Different show, different show Sophie.
这位皇家学会非常年长、非常杰出的成员、皇家学会院士说：“我喜欢被挠痒痒。”我可不会挠你，先生。这可不是——这可不是大多数人的反应。换个节目，换个节目，苏菲。不会挠你的，先生。这可不是大多数人的反应。换个节目，换个节目，苏菲。
Different show. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
换个节目。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。